the
drive from my home to holy cross church
is only a couple of miles away
and you know every single day i pass by
that church
you're always remembering what happened
to you where you were
the pain and the anguish that you
suffered as a young little kid is never
going to be diminished it's never going
to go away
also knowing that where i learned about
god
was also where i learned about pain
[Music]
there are thousands of me all across the
country
and still to this day there are some of
us that have never come forward and will
never come forward
because they're afraid of what their
community what their family and their
friends are going to see
i was very nervous about speaking out
against the catholic church but this is
not about the church this is about
what's doing right for the victims good
evening two men are taking on
two albuquerque catholic churches and
the archdiocese
they say they were raped as boys and
accused the church of covering it up
the diocese is aware of about 500 claims
against them
the archdiocese of milwaukee said it
must file for bankruptcy for
reorganization
the diocese says it filed for bankruptcy
because of clergy
sex abuse payouts the numbers were
shocking the number of
pedophile priests the amount of assets
that were being transferred back
to the parishes across the country or
back to the vatican
so that the catholic church doesn't have
to pay their victims
a lot of archdioceses before they file
bankruptcy they make moves
shift assets they recategorize assets in
ways
that shrink the pot of money that's
available to victims
this is a story about money and church
acting more like a corporation
than a faith-based institution
my name is josh saul i'm a reporter for
bloomberg news and businessweek
and i wrote a story about the catholic
church and how it uses bankruptcy
to shield its money from sex abuse
victims
for most of the 1900s the way the
catholic church dealt with
claims of sex abuse which at that point
was usually just
a mother coming forward and saying my
child tells me that this happened
was they would cover it up uh church
leaders would say we're sorry about this
we'll handle it that priest will be
disciplined or transferred
and it mostly worked they mostly kept it
under wraps so there was an awakening in
the 90s
that there was a problem that began to
appear to be
systemic and then we come to find out
historically it's always been happening
it's just
it's been kept quiet i'm meredith
bennett i'm a lawyer in santa fe new
mexico
may have represented between 100 and 150
cases
could be more that's my best
recollection
they came to us in chain and that was
the tactic
we will make everybody feel ashamed
if they reveal the secret that we're
trying to
tamp down and put in the cupboard and it
worked
but there was still this breakthrough
into the public arena
in the 80s and 90s people started to
file lawsuits against the church
when they themselves or when their
children were sexually abused by priests
the catholic church quickly moved
to set up a system to
quote mediate these cases in other words
to try to get them settled
between the early 1980s and 2002 church
leaders paid about 750 million dollars
in quiet settlements what changed was in
2002
the boston globe spotlight team exposed
for the first time
how priests in that city and how church
leadership in that city
had abused a huge number of children and
had
conspired to keep it all a secret and so
that created a whole second wave
really throughout the country and uh
there's been a movie
made about it since they knew and they
let it happen two kids
okay it could have been you it could
have been me it could have been any of
us
when larger numbers of people started to
file lawsuits
about the fact that they were abused
churches couldn't handle those you know
on a case-by-case basis
so then church leaders had to file
bankruptcy in order to deal with a large
number of lawsuits
i was used to covering bankruptcies of
uh toys r us or sears you know big
companies that filed for bankruptcy
but this was a totally different
situation this was a church
we begin with the top story that we've
been following all day
after years of turmoil the catholic
diocese of buffalo
has filed for bankruptcy the archdiocese
of milwaukee said it must file for
bankruptcy
diocese of rockville center is filing
for bankruptcy almost 30
diocese or church districts in the us
have filed bankruptcy since 2004.
there were at least six bankruptcies by
catholic churches in 2020.
that's a huge increase there have been
years in the past where there wasn't a
single bankruptcy
there were periods where it would take
several years to get to six bankruptcies
there's been a huge increase in the
number of bankruptcies by church
districts
if you're an abuse victim and you have a
lawsuit that you filed against the
church
when the church files for bankruptcy
your lawsuit is frozen it's brought into
the bankruptcy
and then your only option at that point
is to hope for a good settlement
church leaders benefit in a number of
ways when they file for bankruptcy first
it creates uh one central streamlined
process to deal with all of the sexual
abuse lawsuits two
you get a bar after the bankruptcy
nobody can file a lawsuit over past
abuse it's basically a clean slate as
one lawyer described it to me and three
bankruptcy is a quieter process than a
big civil lawsuit
the bankrupt the archdiocese has to
account
and disclose all of its assets
all of its money all of its property all
of its real estate
as part of the bankrupt estate so we
know what we're dealing with all of its
debts and so forth and so on
when we first brought these cases back
in the 90s
we were hearing rumors that real estate
was being put into
blind trusts a lot of transfers of
assets were going on
they could see foresee the avalanche
down the road so what my reporting
showed is that a lot of archdiocese
before they file bankruptcy
they make moves they shift assets they
recategorize assets
in ways that shrink the pot of money
that's available to victims
so i did a lot of work to try to you
know put a number
on the amount of money that the church
had moved from
assets that it owned to its parishes or
to various foundations or cemetery
foundations
and after adding up everything from you
know big big bankruptcies like
minneapolis to you know smaller ones
like gallup new mexico
and all the way back to san diego the
number that i came up with was two
billion dollars
you know if you imagine an organization
that files uh for bankruptcy and they
have
you know 100 million dollars in assets
that's a lot of
money that's a lot of assets that can
then be divided up among victims in a
settlement
if you have that same organization but
they say oh we actually have five
million dollars
in assets that's a much smaller pot of
money that can be divided up among
victims
to boil it down the church shifted money
critics would say that they
hid money into places where it was not
available
for clergy abuse victims
santa fe is a very beautiful community
that
is steeped in tradition and culture it
is a predominantly catholic community
where individuals focus and tend to have
deep pride in their traditions and the
cultures that they've been practicing
for
centuries as a young kid i was raised
catholic went to confirmation went
through all of my catechism classes as a
young kid
i went to catholic school my entire life
and so
religion was a part of me the church
that
i was a part of is santa cruz de la
canada
as a young kid i thought i was going to
become a priest being a part of the
catholic church community
i think as a young kid you you have
reverence and you see these priests and
you want to emulate them
my life changed drastically right around
the age of
of 10 years of age i kind of hold myself
to the position that i allowed my guard
to be down
that's when he took advantage and i
think as a young kid
it really screws with your mind because
you wonder
what you did wrong and you wonder
why it was you
[Music]
i'm now 38 years of age you deal with
this
issue every single day and so for me
my biggest challenge was i knew i was
harmed and i was hurt as a young kid by
this individual all of us do
but the real harm in the real hurt comes
from the fact of what the vatican what
the archdiocese of santa fe
what all these other organizations have
done
to hide this issue and to brush it away
like it was no big issue
that's really where the big hurt comes
from these are the organizations that
should be protecting us
by the archdiocese filing for bankruptcy
they have essentially told every victim
that they don't care
breaking news right now the archdiocese
of santa fe filing for bankruptcy we
have learned the archbishop just called
a meeting with every priest in the
diocese
to a mandatory meeting where he made
that announcement the diocese attorney
says they are currently handling 35 to
40 cases
from people claiming sexual abuse at the
hands of different catholic priests
they have already paid millions of
dollars to victims and survivors
but by filing bankruptcy future victims
will be waiting longer for compensation
there ended up being over 300 sexual
abuse lawsuits filed
against the archdiocese of santa fe in
its bankruptcy
which is kind of amazing to think about
new mexico is not a big state finally
the archdiocese cracked and by cracked i
mean they filed bankruptcy
they basically did that not
because in my opinion that they couldn't
afford
to pay these claims they made it as a
business decision
they thought that this would basically
save them money so when the archdiocese
in santa fe filed for bankruptcy in late
2018
it said we have 49 million dollars in
assets
um but on the same filing it also listed
91 million dollars uh that
it either held on behalf of its parishes
or that it had transferred to its
parishes
so when isaac and i drove around and saw
a sign after sign after sign saying
welcome to the archdiocese of santa fe
on all these different parishes
it again you know seemed to show to me
the close relationship between the
archdiocese and its parishes
[Music]
so the archdiocese of santa fe it's a
big organization it has a cfo has a
chief financial officer
um for a long long time been the same
guy his name is tony salgado you know
people i talked to said like tony's a
great guy he's a really nice guy um he
wouldn't talk to me
um which makes sense one lawyer
described to me he knows
where all the money is he is the one who
put into effect
transfers and the categorizations that
shrank the amount of money
that is available to victims so in 2012
tony salgado called a meeting they
gathered the business managers for its
90 parishes from across the state they
gathered them all together
in a conference room in albuquerque at
archdiocese headquarters and they told
them that
each business manager needed to
incorporate their parish separately
my name is christine romero and i
worked for the archdiocese of santa fe
for
12 years the meeting was
sometime the summer of 2012 the business
managers were called together
to help us understand
how to incorporate the parishes
what that has the effect of doing is it
means that all of those assets that are
owned by the church its building
its collection plate its parking lot all
of that is owned
by the parish not by the archdiocese
i didn't really have any
either negative or positive ideas about
the incorporation
but when i did ask what the impact
was going to be on the parishes on my
particular workload
i asked tony salgado he said that there
would be
no difference that our work would be
exactly the same
that we were incorporating
each parish separately to protect the
parishes from the pedophile lawsuits
that were coming in
to the archdiocese so when christine
told me that
it was uh it was a pretty big deal i'm
like okay great smoking gun
i decided to go on the record because i
don't believe
the catholic church should care about
money we're about
protecting our faith not our money if we
have had abusive priests
pedophile priests that's so unfortunate
but if we have to sell our land or sell
our assets
to help the victims i think we should do
that i don't believe
that we should be protecting monetary
items material things that's not what
our faith is based on
i just didn't realize the bigger
picture of what was happening on a
larger scale
in terms of lawsuits i knew at a
national level there was a lot of
pedophile
lawsuits i just didn't realize the
magnitude
and the number of lawsuits that were
happening
in new mexico tony salgado has not
responded to these claims he's emailed
me back only to say that
i would need to talk to the lawyer
representing the church
by incorporating the parishes separately
and also by moving
parish assets into a trust the
archdiocese moved about 91 million
off of its books into accounts or trusts
by studying past bankruptcy settlements
i came up with a very rough estimate
which was archdioceses often settle for
half of the assets that they initially
say that they owned when they filed for
bankruptcy
so using the 50 number as a rough guide
victims in santa fe
could expect to get about 65 000 in the
settlement
if the church stuck to saying that it
owned just 49 million dollars in assets
but if the archdiocese included all of
this
other money from its parishes its
foundation then victims could expect to
get a lot more or like 300 000
i did a lot of reporting to try to
understand you know what happens after
someone's abused
i talk to a psychiatrist in santa fe who
treats a lot of these victims
basically what i learned is that being a
victim is expensive researchers at johns
hopkins
actually put a number on it childhood
sexual abuse can end up costing
that victim 280 thousand dollars
throughout their lifetime
for me personally as a victim i don't
always believe that money fixes
everything
a sense of community and a sense of
counseling
and rehabilitation is more important
money is just the band-aid that that
fixes a scrape
but we're not really looking as to what
caused the scrape we're not looking at
the long-term effects of that
and so there needs to be a strong sense
of movement
to getting people to help that is is
continuous
and isn't just just temporary
how do you value the damage
that this inflicts on a human being
money's not going to fix it totally but
certainly it could begin to help get
people access to
mental health care to get them to
rebuild their lives and
be able to find a job and try to come
back to
believing that it's not their fault
but things are changing in a couple of
ways uh the bankruptcies now are very
contentious
the victims in santa fe actually just
won a court decision where they can now
sue the church
to bring some of those assets back into
the pot of money that the archdiocese
owns
so here we are with the archdiocese of
santa fe now
facing scrutiny that they'd never faced
before
so i'm not sure where the catholic
church goes with this
this is not unusual by the way this has
happened around the world
certainly when these types of claims
that threatened
uh these assets started to arrive
everything went underground and as far
as their holdings are concerned
so that's kind of where we are now
my hope for the story is that it shows
the people around these bankruptcies
from the victims to the lawyers to the
church leaders you know what's happened
in the past
helps them understand what's going to be
happening at an even greater rate as
more and more
churches file for bankruptcy in the
years to come
i think this issue of child molestation
and bankruptcy is predominant
all across the country from los angeles
to chicago to milwaukee
these are issues that have occurred from
the highest
order all the way down to seminarians
and
young kids have been caught in this
whirlwind
for decades i just want to
reassure the victims of pedophile
priests
that there are some catholics who do
understand and who do sympathize and who
do
support them in their lawsuits and in
getting whatever monetary compensation
they need
to make them and their families whole
again
i think we're about to hit the key point
and we'll see what the church
how they respond to this
[Music]
you